welcome
the direct path number seven
why do we continue making these direct
path videos
ask yourselves a similar question
about why mass media
continues to sell
people conspicuous consumption
and fear on a daily basis
from so many different angles
to provide the direct path teaching
from all of these different
angles the many paths
to the one truth
different pieces and aphorisms
and explanations and analogies
resonate with different people at
different times
in their own journeys in piercing the
veil to self-realize
and that is the intent of these direct
path videos
is self realization
we've been breaking this down in depth
across
our direct path videos as well as on our
instagram
where
we have a visual available
to share with you
in essence the idea of the visual
is that by
choosing
i'll even preface by saying this
actually
once you taste the indescribable
infinite perfection
that this is the question even is why
even do these videos
well this is the way that
the expression is coming through
so this is the artistic expression of
god source infinity non-duality
expressing itself through this quote
individuation
there's a state of enlightenment
a state of pure infinite bliss
and peace causeless joy imperturbable
piece
that is the light bulb staying on which
means
you literally bathe in the ocean of
that all the time
and that's enabled because your separate
self egoic contraction
has dissolved in the
t of infinity
so ultimately at the absolute peak
even before we get into the first bit on
intention
and self-realization and that visual the
first bit to even say
is that once you taste this
indescribable perfection
which literally means that everything is
absolutely perfect exactly the way it is
right now this simply
is perfect it's just perfect there's
no further explanation are you going to
ride the surf are you going to
enjoy all of the different coloration
or are you going to try and package that
up
into a book
and try and describe the indescribable
now this is where again i
explain that the way that
it is expressing itself through me is to
absolutely enjoy the indescribable
perfection
while simultaneously packaging it up
into all these cool
visuals and videos and a
virtual reality pedagogy and animated
series and all this type of stuff
that's what's fun for me is to
describe the indescribable dao
that's what's fun for me
that's just what's coming through
so every single thing that you're gonna
hear is going to
apply to you in some way if you're here
at step one
on identity certain things are going to
apply to you
and you may make some progress if you're
already at step two a complete union
with god
then if your god realized
a lot of what i say in step one you've
already already heard
and if you're already in a state of
indescribable perfection
then
congratulations the way
a great word for this is hermeneutics
the interpretations
visualize the 1000 or more people
that are on the receiving end of this
content
all of them are at different stages in
piercing the veil
some have completely pierced the veil
are already an indescribed perfection
some of them are just in the state of
the i
am the god realization and some people
are still
contractions as an egoic
sugar cube that is being dissolved in
infinity
now most likely those egoic contractions
are watching polarization propaganda
they're most likely consuming high
fructose corn syrup
and fast food and going to bars
and clubs and seeking happiness
externally
and that's the parable of the prodigal
son is that
the consciousness experiencing the
illusion
of going outside of itself in order to
find
happiness and then realizing that it's
actually
endogenous that the diamond necklace is
already around the neck
and that's what option two is in that
graphic
and again you can find that graphic on
our instagram
at simulation series
that's option two so option two is going
outward
and then the egoic pinocchio nose grows
and then it pierces the breaking point
of planetary harmony
which we're experiencing right now and
it's the parable of the prodigal son
where consciousness turns around
and goes inward anyway in its second
step so
option two is outward first then inward
now option one
is where the egoic pinocchio nose does
not grow
it's where you go self-realization first
which is inward first
and now this comes to our intention
which is option one
self-realization first inward first
and what that does is once you become
god realized
you're mostly just silent because what
happens
is is that as lao tzu described
you have wu wei which means effortless
action happens
literally you no longer take action
there is no longer a you that is taking
action
it is literally just god source infinity
the absolute channeling itself through
you of the absolute highest divine
morality period
you'll be in some sort of a setting and
there will maybe be one person talking
or two people talking
and you'll just be sitting there blissed
out peace out
you'll be great and you're sitting there
smiling listening
enjoying the experience
and then when something is asked of you
what happens is
you stay silent and then it might come
up in
500 milliseconds it might come up in two
seconds
it might take you six seconds or even
longer
for the right lightning bolt to
intuitively come through
you no longer do anything that's what wu
way
is it's just absolute effortless action
and it's only granted to those that
self-realize
everything else is an egoic misery show
and that's evident in the
immorality that we see
in the modern economic machinery
but again in a transcendent perspective
everything's already indescribably
perfect
and that's why true simultaneity is key
meaning your ability to see everything
is absolutely indescribably perfect
yet at the same time go on the path of
sahaja
samadhi as ramana maharshi described
is where you take your god realization
and yet
you undergo the tantric path of
weaving the god self-realization
into society so you don't go [ __ ] off
into a mountain
and you also don't sit there when
somebody asks you
a question and just look at them
i'm just so blissed and peaced out right
now that i can't even respond to you and
you just sit there
for minutes and they're like is this
person functional
no you function you weave
that's what buddha meant by the middle
path the middle way
that's what is known as the goldilocks
zone that is why
this planet even exists is because it's
in a goldilocks zone
as above so below as above with
planetary habitable zones
goldilocks zones as below also with
humans and the goldilocks zone or the
middle way or the middle path
yet also dig all the way to water
meaning you can go too far in one
direction or too
far in the other direction which is not
deep enough you didn't actually drill
the well all the way to water
a lot of people are stuck at the
multiplicity this is another graphic on
the
instagram that you can check out a lot
of people are stuck at the multiplicity
some people have dug
down to a little bit of water the first
taste of oneness maybe
and thought that's it i have this
philosophical understanding i'm done
perfect nope it's experiential
indescribable perfection non-duality is
an absolute
again indescribable experiential state
of consciousness and sahaja samadhi
or where you weave your spiritual god
realization into the societal fabric in
a
effortless action wu way
is ultimate that's it
that is the ultimate that's why the
intention of this direct path number
seven is literally
self realize
then silence
relax that awareness into that
self-realization
and then the intuitive lightning bolts
of effortless action
of the absolute highest morality to
weave into society come done
done so
is that indescribable perfection yeah it
absolutely is
is the person that decides to go [ __ ]
off on a mountaintop for 30 years
indescribable perfection
it is as well is the person that
is still trapped in their egoic separate
entity
state also indescribable perfection yes
and that is the transcendent
indescribable perfection that this is
now is the middle path optimal between
being egoic separate self and also
[ __ ] off to a mountain
yeah it is
simultaneity is key can you hold all of
these
perspectives simultaneously and can you
ebb and flow
between them and that's why we just made
that video i've been flowing between
the physical to the absolute true
simultaneity
again for all of these videos and go
watch the last
six if you haven't get yourself in a
comfortable position in a silent
place be in a silent place
be sitting somewhere comfortably
calm your monkey mind with your breath
the deep belly breaths ah
feel your entire body
relax back into your awareness if you're
at advanced stages
relax back into your awareness
the awareness pre-coloration
the awareness that is blank before
the words color it
and just find yourself
undergoing the process of truly from all
of your heart
manifesting as much love and compassion
as you possibly can manifest that love
and compassion for yourself
accept yourself and love yourself
exactly how you are
period that's the indescribable
perfection
now butterfly effect that out
manifest as much love and compassion as
you can like an exploding
supernova all over the planet
every single person is a divine
expression of
god source infinity
only unconditional love only
indescribable perfection for every
single one of them
so beautiful how much fulfillment and
beauty and bliss and peace that this
experience brings me
because it's so natural it's so harmonic
just
riding along on the wave
i'm surfing
and i'm so grateful that there are
people that are commenting
multiple people a day messaging in a lot
of people
are coming in and becoming
more and more excited about
these transmissions so many people are
messaging in now it's so incredible
just like a constant uptick of the
resonance of these transmissions with
people which is fantastic
again before i had the enlightenment of
the light bulb
permanently staying on there was
absolutely
no proclivity tendency whatsoever for me
to be doing
anything like this none it just
it doesn't resonate it doesn't make
sense it only comes
right at the right time right as it's
unlocked for you
the wave is like now transmit
now weave the self-realizations into
society
it will be similar as well for many of
you
across all of the different stages
a hundred percent pure surrender to the
acceptance of yourself the loving of
yourself
the radiance of that absolute
unconditional love and compassion from
your heart
for yourself exactly as you are
as well as for all 8 billion humans for
the entire planet
perfection
and that makes this entire direct path
process a lot easier
if that state becomes home keep
that home love yourself accept yourself
express that love and acceptance across
the entire
planet and that is the indescribable
perfection
to surf that bliss and peace of
self-realization okay
so identity wise
the best analogies so far thanks to
incredible teachers of non-duality like
rupert spyra
which i always highly recommend checking
out you can also
not only go look at his youtube channel
which is fantastic but you can go buy
his books which are fantastic which i am
doing
exegesis videos on which you can go
watch the one we did on the transparency
of things
and next is the nature of consciousness
which is coming soon
his analogies his metaphors are so fire
we have to realize that these analogies
in these metaphors
are the best way to describe the nature
of reality we're going to go through
many of them here
we've already been going through so many
of them but they are the most simple
the most explained like i'm five the
clearest transmissions of the nature of
reality
anything more than these very basic
explain like i'm five metaphors and
analogies
unnecessarily cloud the direct path
teachings
first second there even forgot i was
even
live it's just that much flow
no desire no attachment no craving
no aversion no anything that
feels like this is not already
indescribable perfection
okay so on to the first analogy for
identity the best way to describe
this on
the egoic separate
self
is to contract up right now do it with
me
contract your entire body
right grab your elbows from your arms
contract them inward maybe even raise
one of your shoulders
and then bring the other shoulder down
and contract your whole body inward like
this and then grab
one of your fists probably like you're
right if you're dominant on that hand
and put your left hand
around it and just
clinch your fist as hard as you can
and clench your whole body contract it
all
and don't breathe don't relax at all
just
[Music]
and then relax relax everything and
breathe
[Music]
and that's what eternity feels like
the relaxation is what eternity feels
like
so the contracted
egoic separate entity is like that
nasty completely contracted
state
and then the unwinding of it
ah the relaxing of it the expansion of
it
the release
thank goodness i have stopped seeking
outside of myself for happiness thank
goodness i found the diamond necklace
that is already me
everything's just so indescribably
perfect
and it's been this way and it's going to
continue being this way that is the game
of eternity
is absolute indescribable perfection
eternally yay
understand that this is an expression of
that yay
okay so the first analogy here in the
identity
is the contraction that contracted
fist that contracted egoic body okay
now the second analogy
that plays in really well with it
you are already the fish in the ocean
swim flow your body
okay the second analogy
along with the contraction
is the sugar cube analogy
the sugar cube dissolving
into the hot tea of infinity
what that means is that this first
analogy of the contracted fist
and their you know again as always the
two
are actually one haha another
funny one that's constantly everywhere
okay so these two analogies even with
the contracted fist and the sugar cube
are the same analogy so merge them into
the same analogy
and tell the story this way to yourself
to your family friends co-workers people
online
so that contracted egoic
separate entity is the sugar cube
and as it relaxes
as it undergoes that release and
expansion that is
the sugar cube of that separate entity
ego
that is dissolved into
the hot tea of eternity
infinity god self-realization
one of the most profound aspects to it
is when you realize that the
consciousness or the awareness is shared
you no longer associate yourself with
those onion layers of identity
of oh my name is atlas i live in los
angeles i'm an entrepreneur i'm an
interviewer
i'm armenian
yada yada yada all these onion layers of
identity
rather what happens is you go oh my god
i
am literally god and so are you and so
are
all of us and i now associate myself
literally only with
god with non-dual awareness i am that
that is what i
am i am not my onion layers of identity
that's it
alan has died atlas has died they've all
died
there is no longer a onion layer of
atlas
now albeit true simultaneous key
in the sense that okay hey atlas will
you give me that microphone
yeah yeah no problem i'll be right there
with it you know you
you're not gonna respond to that person
and be like atlas does not
exist i am only non-dual awareness
you know like true simultaneity right
and hopefully these stories and
narratives illustrate the
daily scenarios of the tantric path of
weaving self-realization into the social
fabric and how to do that middle path
that goldilocks zone of optimization
alright so that is your best friend is
the contracted fist
and the sugar cube that
dissolves into the infinity
now
again as that happens it's going to be
really profound because you'll realize
the truth of that pupil
that is shared
the pupil across all eight billion is
literally
shared that that pupil is god you
realize that
and it's just it's just really profound
in general it usually does something
like
it sends you into some sort of a shock
it's really profound
you literally create this juxtaposition
like literally all the time now
now there's no such thing as being lost
in the coloration
of your awareness but now literally you
live in
i am god consciousness ocean
that is experiencing the coloration of
the waves which are thoughts
feelings emotions beliefs objects
so that's what we mean by number two the
union with god what you've done is
you've pierced the veil
right the contracted egoic separate
entity
dissolving like a sugar cube into the
hot tea of infinity is literally
piercing the veil that is what piercing
the veil
means piercing the veil means that you
now
literally live from a place like this
watch the difference is is that you live
in the blank pure bear awareness
and then you understand when
it is being colored by words
you understand that process you know
that process
you are literally i am knowingness
is what you are you're knowing
this entire process that's what happens
and you know that that's what's been
happening this is literally what's been
happening eternally is awareness
has been being colored by all different
types of experience
think about how many infinite
combinations of words
that you could put into books that's
what this is
a massive infinite library
and across all the different creation
designs you have to use your imagination
to think about
what creation designs look like outside
of what we experience here
these two eyes and four limbs and
carbon-based dna
encoded vehicles of for
consciousness for awareness are not
the only way that creation designs are
created
for consciousness for awareness to have
this
fpv first person view perspective
in now ultimately again
on a transcendent perspective everything
is literally just a non-dual
net of being
it's a big ocean and to realize that you
are the ocean and that you're not the
wave
only you are the ocean experiencing the
wave that is what is meant by the
witness the i
am you are the ocean experiencing the
wave
you are not only the wave i am not only
this contracted feeling or emotion that
i'm having
all right so let's keep playing with the
analogies so
the next most important analogy is that
juxtaposition between
the ocean and the wave again
if it's not explained like i'm five it's
not truth
if it's not explained like i'm five if
the metaphor or analogy just doesn't
extremely clearly resonate at a level of
experience it's not truth
that's why all of the complexity that
exists is just not truth
the complexity of the geopolitical
insanity on a planetary level
is not truth of course on a non-dual
indescribable perfection of course is
truth
but in the sense of as rumi says that
throughout all of the
symbols and all of the talking and all
of that fear propaganda and all that
stuff geopolitically
all of the unconditional love is lost
all of it
okay so again your first best friend is
the analogy of the contracted
separate egoic entity the contraction
that dissolves like a sugar cube in the
hot tea of infinity so that's first
the second one again these two are
ultimately one but then what happens is
that that's the recognition
that i am ocean i am
ocean i am infinite i am eternal i
am paper that is being colored
by words
okay so i am ocean
that is being colored by waves
that is experiencing waves i am
screen that is experiencing
applications
eventually we'll also make very simple
explain like i'm 5 content where we
literally just use the screen and then
we use
flashes on the screen of different
content and have
pauses in between that with
the blank screen again for people to
understand this juxtaposition better
okay so this second best friend which
again just is that first best friend
they all work together is that you
become the i
am ocean that is experiencing the waves
it's as simple as that
i'm repeating these analogies over and
over again
because this is the most
optimal way for the direct path
to set in experientially
again that contracted fist of the
separate
egoic entity
that is a sugar cube that relaxes in its
dissolving into the hot tea of infinity
which is the recognition that i am
ocean that is experiencing waves
now
to experience the crest of the wave
is a lot different than experiencing the
front or the back part of the wave the
front and the back part of the wave
and david hawkins does an incredible job
teaching this as well
is that that is where you're basically
even if you have
tastes of this i am-ness you're either
in a state of
constantly preparing future future
future future or you're constantly in a
place of
being on the that tail end of the wave
where you're
you know wondering oh what just what
just happened what was that last wave
about
are you thinking about the last wave
that happened
are you thinking about what next waves
are going to happen
or are you literally on the crest of the
wave that you're on
that is what is meant by the power of
now
eckhart tolle what is meant by simply
this jim newman what is meant
by the presence which is a perennial
wisdom across the spiritual mystic
traditions
and again that becomes natural with
self-realization you
naturally become more and more on the
crest of the wave
silence helps you become more and more
on the crest of the wave
this is another one of those faces up
the mountain as good as the direct path
is
it's really difficult to teach people
that have literally been talking
their entire lives completely non-stop
without even pausing for one
[ __ ] day to shut their mouth what
silence is
have you literally ever spent one day
without saying a word
you know let alone the theravada
buddhism the
direct most conservative teachings of
the buddha where you sit for 10
straight days without talking no eye
contact
no technology no talking for 10 straight
days
because what does that give you surgical
sensitivity
surgical sensitivity to silence
and that is what creates this incredible
understanding of the power of now
it made me understand the crest of the
wave so
fast because i've been to four of these
10-day vipassana meditation retreats
i get the surgical
digging that we did to the roots of
eradicating the suffering
of craving an aversion i get it and i
get the importance of the silence in the
crest of the wave
that's why to have a synthesis
to have had a comparative methodology as
ananda kumar swamy and rene gunnan and
so many of these other
greats have indicated is that
what happens is you create this lattice
work of
concepts like the theravada buddhism is
its experiential teaching
concept of silence which then as you
undergo the direct path teachings of
understanding the juxtaposition of the
ocean and the wave
what naturally happens is that you
connect those two points together
and same thing with your entheogenic
experience and same thing with your
zokchen meditation retreat and same
thing from reading the doubted qing and
same thing from the sufi metaphysics the
same thing
with as we mentioned earlier the parable
of the prodigal son
is a abrahamic story
the old and new testament any of the
african traditions or of the native
american traditions
you create the lattice work and that's
what also
enables you to
optimally
realize the indescribable perfection
so if i was going to add something
i would say again that contraction
that dissolves
into the ocean which then recognizes it
as an
ocean experiencing waves and then i
would add
that continue to
investigate while you investigate the
direct path
investigate the ice cream
of the planetary mystic traditions
they're all different flavors of ice
cream they're all
ice cream is what they are and they're
just different flavors of ice cream
and there's always going to be room for
you to parse
for signal at the top of the ice cream
cone
what is up there what is closest to know
thyself
the delphic maxim that was written 2500
years ago
on the top of the temple of apollo at
delphi
you know what does know thyself mean it
means self-realization because
self-realization leads to silence
leads to effortless action wu wei it
leads to the absolute highest tantric
path
that's why we're doing this video direct
path number seven
so create that lattice work of those
different flavors of ice cream of the
planetary mystic traditions so that way
you're experiencing all these different
faces all these different paths
up to the one truth and you have to
dedicate yourself
that seeking impulse that is within you
to truly pierce the veil to truly
understand what it means to ride the
crest
of the wave knowing that you are the
ocean
that is the truest thing about you
nothing else is as true about you as the
seeking impulse to self-realize
and as ramana maharshi and so many other
greats said that self-realization is
literally the best service that you can
render the world
what's up little bug how you doing bro
it's like the more unconditional love
that you radiate the more animals become
attracted to you
and this is a very you know even people
in the first
you know contracted egoic state clearly
see this and understand this
because for some reason especially you
know dogs and cats the household animals
why do they gravitate to the energy
frequency vibratory levels of people
that are
experiencing states of peace and bliss
more than they do people that are like
the egoic
zippered entity because they're
sensitive
animals are sensitive and they can tell
i'm on a farm up in the north bay
in silicon valley about over a year ago
almost two years ago and the only
way that i could hang out with the cows
was when i went into their massive
pasture
was they all became at first like who is
this guy in our pasture
and then what i did is i literally just
sat down in the middle of the pasture
and then i just laid down and i just
stayed laying down and the cows were
like okay this guy's chill
and then they slowly came up over time
and they started looking at me
literally laying down they were a couple
feet from my face and then
you know you put your hand out and then
they can tell that okay well this
person's not here to injure me
whatsoever and then you start petting
the cows and
you start engaging with them more
harmoniously
and this is similar to how people can
engage with
with lions and this is also similarly to
how people can
even even in these most basic
scenarios of dogs and cats be the person
that the dog and cat loves because they
love your vibration they love your
energy they love your
unconditional love radiating from your
heart
and look at this example right this is
the silence that i'm talking about
if it takes five seconds for you
sometimes
to undergo that intuitive lightning bolt
that comes down as the effortless action
of that unconditional love of the next
what comes of that wave then become
comfortable with that
don't let the modern
instantaneous did
it did again simultaneous key because
sometimes
you can actually get a quick you know
200 millisecond
beat out or message back
learn how to ebb into that silence that
enables the intuitive lightning bolt to
channel through
again woo way effortless action
that's another important concept right
put that into the lattice work
experientially
undergo the process of becoming more and
more familiar with it go and look up
wu-way you know how many times i had to
read wu-way
i probably had to read it over a dozen
times to actually
finally understand it and
again it helped experientially
every month that i would reread the
concept i would get a little bit more
and more and more of it
and now finally being a state of
self-realization
it is really [ __ ] clear what wu wei
means
now there's no misinterpretations
the hermeneutics are so strong the
exegesis is so strong
and at first it's a little bit cloudy
right when you first read the dow to
ching it's going to be a little bit
cloudy
it's going to be hard to understand some
of these things the eternal dao
that can be named is not the eternal dao
at first it's like what does that mean
you know sometimes you don't get that
right away or like that the greatest
illusion is fear
as lao tzu also said and that at first
you're like i don't get how fear is an
illusion
and it takes time to sink in
experientially into the indescribable
perfection
and that's when you go oh my gosh what
an illusion fear is
wow
but you know true simultaneity also
makes it so that as you're walking down
the street and a car
is curving around the corner without
looking and you're very
you know quickly able to you know to
be agile and have agility with
moving out of the way as well
all right so again the egoic
contraction that is the sugar cube
that dissolves into the infinite ocean
which then recognizes itself as the
experiencer
of the waves and then also
the lattice work and creating that
lattice work of experiential
wisdoms that then get to stitch together
on the many paths to the one truth
this third
piece of the absolute is extremely
subtle
it's very very subtle you transcend
the i am observer itself
you transcend the experiencer itself
you transcend the
the experience even as the i
am observer you transcend both of those
into what is an agentless and
attribute-less
formless
ness
and if you practice things like the
white skeleton meditation
i'm very grateful to anthony flores
we've had on the program for introducing
me to that
and he's an incredible
advanced meditator and neurofeedback
savant
and a huge hugely influenced by ramana
maharshi and many other greats
and if you go and look up that white
skeleton meditation
that's another way to experientially be
able to undergo
the process again you re really requires
the highest levels of sensitivity and
subtlety
to actually be able to be able to
transcend
even the experience or even the observer
itself
and some people stop at the i
am and because
they have a process of saying something
like that
is already it that is already the
formless
that is it usually it's also the same
people that
stop with the enjoyment of being on the
crest of the experience and whatnot
most of the greatest spiritual
leaders that have ever existed have went
through
a deeper process of that nirvana of that
moksha of that satori of that sahaja
and it makes it so that there is really
the true experiential knowledge of that
absolute beyond
even the observer of the i am
and that also gives you an imagination
that the i
am observer is not limited to just this
style of white paper blank
pure bear empty awareness there's many
other ways for the white paper to be
expressed itself in many ways
it's like the parts of
the ocean themselves that are located
in different areas of the ocean again
location being something
that is something that we're adding into
the analogy to help because location
itself does not
exist but that way you can understand
that if you're at the mariana trench
that that's going to be a little bit
different than if you're maybe
closer to one of the continental shelves
but you're still
maybe a couple thousand meters
deep there
and what that means is that that
oceanicness itself
that that observer itself has many
different expressions
again we're locked in even some of the
greatest spiritual teachers
of today are locked in to the observer
being the
style that it is being expressed in or
as and so it's important to understand
that there's many different ways to
express
even an observer itself you have to
imagine things like
something like a spirit right an
actual spirit itself that is an observer
that is also
like look at how gross right this is
just very gross this is a very
physical experience
yet there are many other potential
creation designs that exist
where there are nowhere near
as physical of vehicles
for awareness or consciousness itself to
be in it's all the ocean
yet there's many different ways for
the paper to undergo the process
of the waves or the words
maybe another good analogy is actually
the oceans of
methane that are on titan which is a
moon of saturn
there you go that's actually probably a
better analogy
so now you're literally looking over at
titan and we're sending spacecraft there
and then we ourselves will eventually go
and explore the celestial bodies at a
deeper level
and what we're wondering is oh crap
you know or another one is jupiter
because jupiter has
europa and also
saturn has enceladus and so
these are moons of jupiter and saturn
that literally have oceanic
on them that could be potentially
home to completely different awareness
or consciousness which in itself
is in many ways like the blank paper
itself
yet again if in the process of
being the blank paper that is in methane
there is a very fascinating style
of creation design aspect to that that
goes even beyond our own solar system
beyond our own universe into the other
creation designs
but its most fundamental level i do
agree at a most fundamental level
it is very much like a blank paper
that is being colored by words or
the ocean that is being ex that's having
the experience of waves at the most
fundamental level
it really requires imagination to
go outside even this creation design so
this is what is usually meant by the
indescribable perfection once there is a
sort of
true
oceanicness that has been
the light bulb staying on the
recognition
of those waves as
experiences and then that
slowly more and more leads to if you
experience and explore a agentless and
attributelessness
that is very clearly the infinite
indescribable perfection again that's
why
absolute indescribable perfection or
absolute
infinite perfection there's just the
words
miss it they miss the mark of the
absolute
and the best we can even do is literally
write you know agentless or
attribute-less like that's literally the
best we can write
and that's why many of the greats also
call the i am stage or the
self-realization stage that similar
stage of in a sense being agentless or
attributeless
but at the same time there is that
simultaneous
witness or that experiencer
that is commonly referenced in this
self-realization stage
which again that's why at the very top
right sahaja samadhi
is the weaving it's the tantric path you
weave the self-realizations
in a style of effortless action of
channeling the absolute highest morality
into the society
that's the highest intention
i hope this has been helpful and
i would love to hear where you're at
along
your journey let me know in the comments
below i'll do my best to come in there
and we'll get better and better at
setting up these mirrors
for us in this community to help one
another
along the journeys
the journey is the destination every
single
crest is
the destination it's not
when the crest gets to the buried
treasure on the island that then it will
be happy
right all these analogies intertwine and
intermix keep your lattice work really
robust
again if this made a profound impact on
you like the video
subscribe if you haven't share the video
with people that you know that this
would
resonate with and make a an epic
impact on
check out the other six direct path
videos if you haven't yet and
hold these explain like i'm five
analogies and metaphors very closely
very dearly they're the most simple
direct path explanations and check out
rupert spyra if you haven't yet not only
his
youtube channel but his collection of
books he does a very good job at
distilling with these metaphors
and again it's that contracted
egoic separate entity
that relaxes
as it dissolves the sugar cube dissolves
into the ocean
that then recognizes the juxtaposition
of being the ocean the i am
ocean the god or self-realization which
then experiences
the waves and it becomes better and
better at riding the crest
of the waves
and then there's the step even beyond
the observer
to an agentless and attributeless
indescribable perfection
and this all is indescribable perfection
and that's the ultimate realization is
that this
is already hella perfect literally your
consciousness your awareness
itself literally as an ocean
experiencing all these waves
is unbelievable that this even exists
it's so [ __ ] cool
and so that in itself should bring you
enough jaw-dropping
ah
to recognize
the indescribable perfection to
recognize the diamond necklace that is
already around your neck
and also check out these
visualizations if you haven't yet that
are on the
instagram
in future videos i'll also take the
image and put them in the note to be
able to reference
here for you as we go to become even
more efficient i love you very much
thank you for tuning in and
self-realization is the greatest
service that you can render
the world
[Music]
life is so beautiful
life is so fun
this is miraculous
recognize it and be one